[Music]
jessica is in dallas hi Jessica
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up hi so I am calling because right now
we're on baby step two trying to pay off
some student loans and some car payments
that we got ourselves into and we
currently rent we've been renting for
about three years and seeing as we are
projecting the pay off all of our debt
which is about one hundred and sixty
thousand dollars and five to six years
we didn't know what is your dad it's
from student loans and just car loans
how much do you owe on these cars the
cars it's 25,000 and 30,000 stupidness
stage
selim okay why would you drive a $30,000
car when you're broke
we'll see the thing is we looked at
selling and my husband was concerned on
getting less money back than what we oh
yeah yeah you have to cover the
difference I'm sure you're upside down
but maybe you owe $5,000 and you're
driving a beater instead of oh and
$30,000 what's your whole income right
now we just moved so it's 90 thousand
and I'm looking for a job right now
what will you be projected to mank if
I'm making my made at my previous job
about thirty three thousand eight years
okay so we're talking about $125,000
household income you have a hundred and
sixty thousand dollars in debt and you
have fifty five thousand dollars and
card debt yes does that sound stupid
when I say it out loud we know it's
something that we regretted a solemn
basically after it was done so okay and
get on a written budget and cut your
lifestyle to nothing at a hundred and
twenty-five thousand dollars income you
can be out of that a whole lot faster
than five or six years shouldn't take
you anywhere near that long
especially if you get out of these
stupid cars they're absurd thanks for
the call